it's peak holiday season but this
elephant sanctuary is quiet around 40
people a day should be visiting but the
reserve is closed Thai authorities have
temporarily shut down the camps to
prevent the spread of coronavirus soon
we're going to see all of the plants are
going to start to struggle financially
trying to find food to feed the
elephants and to pay their staff while
the animals here are retired and free to
roam during the day many of Thailand's
4,000 domesticated elephants bring in
money through rides the absence of
visitors has led to concerns about
welfare the riding camps that were
catering for the Chinese it says they
actually closed early February
if the elephant's aren't already there
then going to have to be mostly the
places will be training their elephants
24 hours a day which is obviously it's a
bittersweet because the elephants are
getting rest from riding but then also
they're not getting any exercise at all
the tops around 600 pounds a month to
feed an elephant and that's a huge
amount of money when there's no income
coming in and for some they're now
facing the difficult choice between
looking after their families or the
animals the hoop worked has been looking
after elephants all his life his camps
secured funding for the next few months
but there are warnings at least a
thousand elephants across the country
could starve that's what we're most
afraid of he tells me food is expensive
drought means there's little grass and
some owners have already run out of cash
[Applause]
while this sanctuary is hoping donations
will keep them going while they're
closed others are already a crisis point
with potentially months without work
ahead the lives of a quarter of
Thailand's domesticated elephants could
be at risk
siobhan Robbins Sky News